introduction hey everybody welcome back
to recon because he's been bitching at
me since we started in Y so welcome to
another episode of rant cafe back on
this channel on this last two weeks we
were on knocks tacos Channel and oh cool
exposing Ranke faith for a new audience
that was but now we're back here and
this episode will be discussing the
worst anime of 2017 we will be here a
while
it is going to be quite the discussion
we have NOx Taku and anime recon joining
me and hopefully Briggs from old anime
is gonna be coming in as well and maybe
so Mach I'm not sure about him today but
either way welcome back recon after two
weeks of being off yeah if nobody knows
why happened off for the past two weeks
because I new houses and yeah it was it
was like I was just it's such a
nightmare but now everything is good
I've settled and I am I'm back so yeah
it's good and all that I paced an anime
so that's why you've been off as well no
I do not have a bad taste in anime like
for I'm glad you're here though for the
worst anime 2017 because I want to feel
like these are gonna be in your top 10
list for the year that we all hate so I
am curious haha leave that okay I was
thinking that we should tell anime list
well just you know I'm gonna actually
say why I didn't like this year this
year like I'm gonna be honest and if you
guys don't agree with me then I don't
know you guys we will see if you
actually like if you dislike anything of
the rest of the world disliked or if you
were like disliking like stuff everyone
else liked because that tends to be your
your thing well yeah Knox welcome man
going great good to be back on your
channel or I get to do the interrupting
even though I did most of that last week
anyway yeah yeah isn't it isn't it fun
when you don't have to host and then you
can just interrupt and be a I guess we
could switch off on the pleasure
well yeah it's good that you got her the
strikeout of Mac how was so how'd you
get rid of it did you wait all right
feeling it so I haven't heard back yet
like YouTube is you did approve my
appeal so when you appeal a copyright
strike you have to request YouTube to
actually look it over and see if it's a
legitimate appeal or if you're just you
know posting whole episodes of anime
when you still want it removed when they
see that it's a legit appeal then they
approve it then it goes to the company
and then the company has to either say
no we're gonna sue them in court or
allow you to keep the video up and
obviously I'm still waiting on that but
I can't imagine I'm suing me in court
for reviewing and giving my own
commentary on a manga chapter a manga by
the way that you can find the entire
thing on youtube right now without
commentary so if they tried suing me
that would be quite an adventure since
basically I would set a precedent if
they want a case like that against
anybody it would basically mean that any
anime youtuber who does reviews or
analysis could be sued or have their
stuff taken down so yeah like hopefully
it's not gonna come to that but if it
did I would have to fight it because if
you know if you let something like that
go pretty much every anime YouTube or
any film reviewer is done
yeah the adventure yeah it's an
important precedent to fight in case you
can we'll just be you know Jake Paul's
because just like guys what's up guys
gonna shake my camera guys
[Laughter]
merch in the bio rich link in bio bro
some children some guys in the Chad
caster from life always hear dramatic
always hear rising star wild says he's
new to the channel and so on well come
from everybody and yeah I don't know who
wants to start off with like when you
think of worst anime 2017 which comes to
mind right away and chat let me know
what you guys think as well but Knox to
you first
me first recently the short anime I mean
like the three minute per episode anime
those guys they used to be like cute
comedy skits
no now it's all porn it's like you know
not even thank you we have this
three-minute one where it's a dude who
dresses as a girl and then rapes another
girl until the other girl realizes that
they're longer
Nonaka yeah you remember its name but
for you congratulations
Oh one way we got honestly or with you I
dropped it I did drop it no yes
you I thought that was your thing no
it's not my thing I don't want that [ __ ]
I saw a few people in the chat
commenting a commenting are saying hand
shakers and that is definitely one of
the ones that I think of first as soon
as I think of bad anime I only saw the
first episode I was like no this is a
disaster
however it's definitely one of the ones
that comes to mind right away
why we Mak a lot is in child what's up
man why aren't you in the stream what's
going on with you bro my mom is too busy
you know original ink I saw I saw
Michael it's video of a dressing room oh
oh yeah big new amazing yeah Mac will
not finally publish this video where he
cosplays as a rama and apt so basically
ram fanboys your nightmare is here your
nightmare is here it's all over for you
good game no rematch Amelia best girl I
did comment on this video saying is this
a trap hey Mac Ahmad says no one invited
me what are you making problem man no no
but he doesn't he didn't tell me he's
available
if I knew he was available I didn't
white him I'm obviously not too late
send him a link right now also I'm sick
right now let's see if he was bluffing
he was bluffing
yeah if he shows up though I hope he
shows up cuz you know I'm not mrs. face
I miss his moustache
he likes to hate on bad anime like the
buff that recon like enjoys so okay so
knocks knock said what did you say again
I'm short enemy like there was that one
no noise yeah
Nonaka there was the other one that was
just this season also I don't know guy
in his teacher no this is just too much
of this I don't understand there was one
of his bald monk dude and this girl I
don't get it
my god one was the [ __ ] and bad
compared to the other ones the monk dude
was like you know there's getting it on
your skin off yo easy
there he is Mackenzie how do you know
that that's my name that's oh does it oh
well there you go
anyway anyway Mackenzie recon did you
say what comes what comes welcome by the
way
Mac Khan did you say what your least
favorite animal was the worst and we
have pops into your mind right away
um there's a lot but I'm gonna have to
go with it okay finish talking as I said
I didn't like you know manga sensei
because the whole premise of the show
was just little brother wanting to [ __ ]
his little sister I mean I could just
instantly read the guy's mind yeah he
definitely wants to do it dude you don't
need to read his mind you just need to
read the description to the anime the
description of the anime book they got
watching I'm like and there's like this
naked [ __ ] elf just I don't know what
the same I just the whole show was just
bad I disagree with you as far as bad
anime this year this didn't even come
close to the pinnacle of horridness that
actually happened okay for me
well era manga said it was a trash anime
but it was definitely a lot more
enjoyable than like half the other shows
that you seem to put on the top of your
romance list for the year how'd you miss
the nogal coin oh oh so all that garbage
coin also was great bro what are you
talking about boy goes oh don't methanol
I love koi suru so
love it with all your heart and soul we
have someone in the school is amazing so
I just weed obviously a joke so you know
it's not Universal some people
apparently enjoy Dara Mike I see the
problem I have is with horrible anime I
watched like one episode that I move on
so I can't comment comment deeply on it
but Mac Mackel not the main ooh that is
in your opinion the first time that
comes to mind when you say worst anime
2017 hand shakers like right off the bat
other than that I really wasn't a fan of
there was one that I watched with
cyanide blizzard whose jet and a scholar
and a fine judge of horseflesh if you're
watching this back mr. Blizzard we we
made a first impressions on it and I
forget what it was but there it was
these little like frame arms girls maybe
oh that is trash it was it was it was
pretty seen hey we agreed on something
this is a good thing can we I think we
can probably all agree it wasn't the
yeah it wasn't it wasn't the best show
to come out this year there were worse
there I'm sure there were better there
were definitely better but like I ain't
ancient mangas bride I started watching
that the other day amazing but then I
think back await hand shakers was was
pretty [ __ ] so it's it's kind of a matte
year for me mm-hmm
no I'll definitely agree with you
because in terms of how many actually
really good anime we've had I think you
can probably count them you know I'm one
finger on one hand last week we don't
know the best last week we had you know
like attack on Titan season 2 I loved
and uh I hear I could Amy I personally
loved garrow vanishing line for as an
action anime well yeah there's just not
that many really really good ones I
think called a tsuba season 2 was this
year as well so that was a good one but
yeah like a lot of crappy ones like yeah
hand shakers saw the first episode had
to drop it also a clockwork planet oh my
god
oh yeah remember quarters like I really
like steep look you guys know I've
written steampunk before I really like
it so I was like oh [ __ ] clockwork
planet you know a steampunk anime you
know what else is a steampunk anime Full
Metal Alchemist so you know this this is
gonna be good and I watch and the first
frickin episode girl randomly sucks
dude's finger falls out of the sky like
on to him randomly sucks his finger and
[ __ ] I was like is it someone's finger
though like awkward planet in my opinion
was they didn't just make it in tight
they should just should have gone that
route you know girl falls out of the sky
he fixes her you have two options you
have a crappy anime like no finger
sucking you get the power from sucking
the fingers of those around her that's
well she doesn't
what she had to do she can be connected
to him get his approval she had to suck
his finger so they can be together but
yeah that was quite random that's a
thing this is this is something that
maybe recom can answer but why do these
anime exist contract Anna Mack they she
have to make a contract with them no but
it's just like these anime have terrible
plots and they they're just pandering
who you know fanboys it's like oh look
this random guy that's you know totally
average just gets hot girls to suck his
finger randomly like you know it just
happens but like why not just man guy a
hentai because that's what it is it's a
fantasy you know what's up high fantasy
for people so why not just make it a
hentai rather than trying to make it
into an anime with that it's there's no
plot is just fanservice and yet it's not
all the way hentai so it's like like
what is the purpose and I think you
enjoy some of these anime recon which is
why I asked you to I did not enjoy
clockwork planet I actually develop it
as well and episode 6 you made it
episode 6
Wow and I just got bored I was like [ __ ]
yeah I just don't care anymore so yeah I
just I couldn't continue the show
anymore
ah fyz on says
Pingo in the city best anime 2017 uh
it's better than some of the stuff we've
talked about so is penguin the city
actually a thing yes it is it is an
actual anime all right well it's been
extreme with you then I'm off to go find
max yeah the world is not as you left a
Mac when you decide attack and career
and stopped regularly showing up the
rank of faith things have changed man
sorry it's cool now off damn
alright by the way we have a guy called
narutards Punk in the chat and I'm
pretty sure does just knock stock was
ill nice with my channel probably hey
hey you know what you know what he
probably did but even if he didn't he
should definitely check out your channel
because ah it's a great place if you're
not [ __ ] enough
I would say it's an even better place
than double for animes channel because
all the day not much of a compliment he
has some great shirtless memes you have
better content means so you know it's a
trade-off but in the end right script
for him I picked for him to say without
shirts man that would be amazing man
yeah I would that would be like cuz you
would actually not get ultimate so
channel you would actually make it funny
and interesting and yet he's doing it
without his shirt with a scarf with a
[ __ ] like one of those Peruvian llama
alpaca scales scarves I guess i'll naka
and that would be great man i think this
is ooh this is a collab that i want to
see happen everybody knocks what are you
gonna do with thanks for veal base
reveal happening
eventually i thought that's what your
face look like like right in your
profile picture
yeah looks nothing like knucks I want to
see the real looks I want to see how he
looks like right feel free to come to
attack booth on oh okay so now [ __ ]
park says he loves Daniel T target
anymore than Naruto so
just don't know what to believe anymore
now like this is just this is just this
is just crazy 2017 everybody has been
crazy it's Naruto the anime about the
Pirates no Naruto is born into that
other ninjas all right oh yeah [ __ ]
evenin gentlemen its dad the pirate one
that you're talking about anime I mean
sorry
Mackinaw is one piece versus pirates
yeah anyway so rising wants us to get
back on track in the chat well then he
can suggest some terrible enemy for us
well this what is the worst anime you oh
I know what season Oh your enemy you've
seen this season oh well see that's the
thing like I said hand shakers and no
this season this season
yeah season he was there was kings game
that takes the cake for really bad anime
that could have been good see here's the
problem for this season I waited for
people to tell me which are anime are
good and I only ended up watching good
ones so the animal watching this season
are like vanishing line quino's journey
Magus pride what else
black clover which definitely should not
be grouped in this no I like Buckland
yeah like some other ones right so I
would not say any of them are terrible
and yes I do watch black clover and no I
don't think it's terrible nice judging
me I [ __ ] like I hear people judging
me like shut up
okay feel the judgment Isis I just did
on my channel an honest description on
every anime of the year three titles in
one video in any case that's not the
point
my brother calls me and he says to me
hey I just watched your video why'd you
make black clover a C+ when it's amazing
yeah it was a pretty scary moment
for me I would say the worse time I've
seen are to the season it is Kings game
and Ginny Tyson I didn't like them both
okay well Junie Tyson is not a bad enemy
by any means but Diaz Irae or dies not
nice right yeah that's that that's a
crappy one man disaster of an anime but
yeah yeah I haven't seen that one
I forgot to say that I'm watching Junie
Titanic and Briggs is here with us I
don't know if he's completely with us or
just his avatar and I'm in this this no
the party starts now
holy crap yeah he Briggs said that not
man we thought raised your mic is too
low low man yeah he's trying to talk we
can't can't hear nothing breaks okay
here it definitely has its moments where
you're like what the [ __ ] and you get
frustrated especially that like the
dragon and snake dudes were like why are
these people in this show however
overall I am really enjoying the show
Knox you were right about that latest
episode it took things in a totally
different direction that I wasn't
expecting much better than I was
expecting
so I have to agree with you Junie Tyson
is actually a good anime it's overdue
final episode
yeah well I saw the one though the final
ones bit of a letdown
yeah yeah I saw the one where you figure
out rats power yeah that wasn't pretty
amazing yeah that's what sucks last time
scene I was like damn Knox was right
this was good
oh well predicted sort of the entire end
of the show
whoa program for an emergency broadcast
system
Briggs is some 1930s radio show effect
music Marcia just landed I don't know
why my like your phone's not working
hi pipe tell us we're anime 2017 what
comes to mind first thing first conquer
mine Dragon Ball super manga yes
honestly can I say block clover even
though I love it no it's a [ __ ] good
show I mean it but then like nothing's
happened yet
help me up so there they are they like
eight episodes in no there's more like
doctor four of the manga like village
and they confronted some like cult of
powerful magicians and [ __ ] like a long
has happened what do you mean yes I saw
the Wizard Kings that I liked like so
much about block clover was how
fast-paced it was like one action fight
after another when I read the manga and
like they're still at that part that
sucks I stopped watching it after he
like seven or eight episodes because
nothing had happened yet oh well they
have to stretch it to 50 episodes for
the first season so that's why this is
happening however I have heard really
good things about the manga fine son
told me a little odd that I need to read
the manga so I will eventually probably
on the Fenian but like right now
like I said as I'm watching it I'm not
hating it or anything I'm just kind of
chillin watching and I'm not saying it's
like a masterpiece it doesn't make me
think like oh [ __ ] just blew my mind but
it's definitely entertaining same thing
like Dragon Ball super like I think
that's a very entertaining action atom
especially this latest arc and also the
Future Trunks arc and also the universe
six arc like I feel like those they're
you know the Frieza
arc and certain arcs are very like what
the [ __ ] however I feel there's a long
you know a lot of the action and stuff
if you compare like durable super Dragon
Ball Z Man Dragon Ball Z you had like
one fight for 30 episodes
super doesn't do they don't have as much
filler so I'm totally cool with me and
nuts like ripping on you but I'm
actually like I still enjoy Dragon Ball
super
doesn't watch it but like I know you do
what about mr. anime uh poor son just
listen for singing why do you not watch
any good shonan's there are so many good
shonan's there are you don't watch any
of the good ones you haven't watched one
piece you ever watch shokugeki no souma
you haven't watched hunter hunter you
haven't watched anything like you
haven't or chester is not working an
airing man okay well soma is i will
probably end up watching food wars
because it's been recommended to me so
many times you're missing out I'm gonna
read the manga eventually but I don't
wanna watch me which is because so many
episodes like that I will really long
you might wanna catch up because it is
getting emo on a byte so I think ball
supers is a pretty good Shonen but I
didn't watch any good shonan's it's
getting a fourth season and get up get
off your high horse
Dragon Ball super the aesthetic is
really nice even though the plots
terrible the characters aren't improving
and even though the fight still makes
sense if there's no confident the
aesthetic man this is snob says did you
bro yeah dad aesthetic though by the way
let me say this caster for life asked
whether I'm going to use my internet
Geass on him buddy I already have why do
you think you're here for every stream
for every video think about it you think
you think you're here cuz I'm
entertaining bro no you're here because
I commanded you reach creators first
anime of the year you say that I'm like
I don't I don't agree but I'm really
happy to hear it because quite frankly
I'm just so happy that someone is
disagreeing with you know I tried
I honestly tried like three times to
watch the show I dropped it all three
times I got to like Episode five or six
I think like you just it was such a
struggle I did not enjoy it at all the
characters are blanks you just continue
watching it watching it no yes you do
that you will see greatness it's not as
you continue throughout the episode
throughout the episodes you will see it
will get better and better
no I will I will definitely say in terms
of readers I wouldn't say it's one of
the worst anime and but I would
definitely agree that it doesn't keep
you you know keep you interested the
characters are not that interesting that
the pace gets very slow at times so yeah
I def I could didn't finish it myself I
got like 13 episodes in and that's the
problem right it's not terrible but it's
not great and I find it interesting that
we did not talk to every creators very
much last week when we were talking
about the best anime because it just did
not end up being a modern classic NOx
but it wasn't a modern classic it wasn't
a modern classic quite frankly enriched
was an original series but what I like
down the creator's was the last few
episodes I'm not watching all show for a
good last episode and also you don't
have to is no matter what happened no
matter fight what fights were happening
it all ends up with meteora coming up
with some crazy idea that saves the day
but it doesn't actually accomplish
anything because they just sort of back
off until the next episode where they
fight again there's no progression in
the entire story until I guess so 14 or
there's this massive plan and then
you're back to square one again let's
just say it definitely belongs more in
this stream than last extreme I tend to
agree if we do it most mercury then we
could talk about it more this just hit
me what about that was a gold it's a cow
a smartphone in another world with my
smartphone I was gonna bring it out yes
I did I am yeah I just said what's more
typical so I know it's a harem but I
just basically sword art online in a
different setting except it knows it's
wrong
I'm gonna have to stop it right there
not like saon
okay tell me what's the difference
between the main character Toya the main
character of smartphone and cue Tito
tell me okay um okay they don't have a
difference but he was too overpowered in
that show which I did I'm like you know
lost like half the fights
Kirito Kirito literally just said oh
[ __ ] the game and killed the bad guy for
no reason even though okay by the way
here it so hot development okay oh yeah
I was like oh he's dead oh no he's not
blahblah because he's cured - that's
guys let's try not to talk over each
other one at a time but in terms of that
it is surprising that recon didn't enjoy
that because he likes harem he likes
sword art online there's a lot of
parallels however that could also be it
right like you can have an anime that's
really similar to sort out online
well because it's so similar you don't
like it because you already you're like
I've already seen turned out online this
is trying too hard to be that so I do
understand recons perspective from that
in that sense just because you know you
like a certain animal doesn't mean you
want to watch a bunch of a man that are
so like that that you're like man this
is a blatant copy what Mac either that
are you with this rant cafe and he is
now developing yes okay knocks okay
development for recon but again one at a
time guys Mac why did you bring up recon
I just said one at a time Mac why did
you bring out a smartphone well your
your personal thoughts on that and did
you actually end up finishing it or just
like I think I watched like the first
three episodes and I was like I watched
like the first two when my roommate was
watching it and I was very done by the
end of the first one but I had nothing
to do by the time the second one starts
I'm like it
I'll just do it wasted 30 minutes a
melon
yeah like I thought the problem with
that show is again it just gets a bunch
of things from different anime and then
when I saw the guy comes into this world
and it's like oh you have all six of the
[ __ ] powers I was just like oh my god
like wow there is with smartphone at
least it knows it's stupid okay that is
definitely an advantage that's you know
pretty sure I laughs - it was not stupid
for sure right that Ted show is
brilliantly written and stuff mm-hmm
yes Sao is brilliantly written but you
please why are you talking about sorting
online in a stream about worst anime
recon oh you keep you brought it up
cause you don't like it oh no you
brought it up mr. Kyle smartphone and
suddenly you say no this is a non-issue
I already explained that he's allowed to
like sort on a lot and not a show that's
blatantly trying to copy it the problem
with smartphone is it knows it's stupid
but it's still stupid it's not like a
one-punch man where it's like a satire
or like or like my favorite Keijo you
know it's a joke you know they're being
over-the-top and in-your-face with
certain things you know exposing tropes
and stuff I got and yet they do it well
whereas this one like smartphone and not
just smart for like so many of these is
Sakai and other anime they take a bunch
of tropes that they know fans like so
your you know your harem your little
sister whatever you're overpowered come
to another fantasy world where everyone
loves you and you have all this power
like they take that and they beat it to
death to the point where like all just
when I please tell you something rising
mentioned in the chat and it's possibly
one of my least favorite anime the
entire year go for it throw it out
online ordinal scale
I really appreciate it because ordinal
stick I personally enjoyed the first
season of sparta online when I watched
it I did like it
I liked the fights I've even rewatched
certain fights and when I would take
clips from the show to use in my videos
I would often finish off the clip just
like because it's cool when I don't know
cue Tito beats Eugene order the Hellfire
guys anyway that's not the point
ordinal scale was one of the worst anime
I've seen this year are you double
double the movie yes not seen the sword
our online movie however that came out
this year so that's definitely a
legitimate topic for this stream I loved
it I loved that that's all I can say
well no but like that's not an argument
though just saying you loved it
and I say oh so many times I always tell
you guys I want I love the show anything
that comes from sao any like anything
any show that is really as sao I just
instantly love it so I think you're at
like you're at the point with Sao like
with me till one piece essentially they
could do anything wrong and you're still
gonna somewhat like love the series yes
so there's the slight but you're trying
to convince him that don't worry your
your thought process actually makes
sense and since you said that he agrees
I'm not the worst ignored I didn't find
ordinal scale bad at all I've watched
the movie in in the cinema and yeah I
liked it about it no one else here
watched it but like as far as things
that happened key vetoes did something
new pit and beat the bad guy even though
he made no sense
quite frankly because he's not
physically fit really at all and the
other guy was training for this for a
while and he just sort of whooped his
ass because cue Tito power and yeah the
girl in the real world in an audience it
wasn't the real world it wasn't real
world is again Knox is right about this
because the whole point
sword art online is that kid itõs really
skilled as a gamer in the virtual world
but he's just an average guy in the real
world so when they bring it into the
real world your Pokemon gold style now
you know pointing out something like how
is he tall or something so fit and able
to fight in the real world is a
legitimate criticism well I that's not a
fair criticism the whole freakin movie
with one big legitimate criticism
everyone claims though asana was so
great what did I ask him to do she walks
up to the bad guy she gets beaten she's
all sad now so she's in bed for like the
whole rest of the movie and Kuby just
like don't worry white couch on I will
save you ha ha that sounds like most of
Sao did they change anything or is there
well at least in regular Sao sorta
better was there at least our training
compilation like for him it would like
the next day though I did like some of
the awesomeness scenes that were being
shown in the film that was like was
dying in bed of sadness to listen a lot
of you guys like no game no life no game
no life is in no way better than sword
art online it's the same [ __ ]
exact same [ __ ] overpowered main
characters for no good reason
complete pandering to fans the same
tropes over and over again they they win
no matter what
ok so I disagree with you completely
because I love no game no life and then
bro-beans smart isn't over by tonight
can I say a major difference between
soda and Kirito let's see let's see
major differences key tito had a very
baseline personality his personality
didn't really grow or shrink he sort of
kept it throughout and he was also
overpowered because he was a much better
gamer than everyone else
all right now sorta on the other hand
had a wacky personality that was very
fun to watch and he won because he was
smarter than his opponent I'm like
here's the value or else or else you
could say that a code geass
code Joss is like another sword on the
line blue she's just stupid yes
than everyone nobody can find control
every stupid oh my god it's like
watching angry after how are you
imprinted impression was that yeah and
not knocked knocks that not made so much
sense because oh yes which came out
before was copying sword art online you
know no here's the before it's ordered
online got its enemy to allow me I'm not
saying that no gaming live copied sort
our line I'm just saying that it's the
same type of stuff so if people enjoy
one and the other it's the same [ __ ]
because with Sora he's not smart to the
point of like light versus Keita or
Lelouch or you're like oh I see I see
what he's thinking he starred this
through he's smart at the point it's
like oh yeah I I thought ten steps ahead
of you and everyone watching to the
point but it was impossible it was
impossible for anyone to predict what
was gonna happen or to see your logic or
follow your logic so it is it's just OB
it's pretty much his intelligence is
deus ex machina which is the problem
with that show he and then of course the
pandering big emote oh [ __ ] the
fanservice that it's not like there's no
cause for just random scenes of
fanservice like that type of stuff I
don't like if I don't make it classy
okay look dude I don't like the random
fanservice either the whole point of the
show was an air of stupidity that you
can enjoy that was the basic idea but in
this era of stupidity with characters
that are socially moronic they're also
geniuses in their own way and the
calculation they make aside from the
coin toss at the end of the anime the
decisions and the geniuses that they the
plans that they come up with do make
sense there is a or underlying thought
process look at the lucious plans let's
set a volcano off twice let's record a
conversation ourselves talking the other
day
why doesn't me Thank You CLE like I if I
was Lelouch if I was a loose and I
looked at my options I could have
thought of that but no one could have
thought of Shiro and Sora's plans
because their intelligence is apparently
at such a level that it's pretty much
powered like any kid 800 people is their
intelligence their ten steps ahead of
everyone including the audience the
audience can't catch up so it's
basically just like oh how are they
gonna maneuver everyone now but that's
like the enjoyment and like at least
with like with Sao he's strong for no
reason at least there's like they're
giving you information about how he
defeated his opponent like half the time
it's like how did he do it like it like
you wanna think it's kinda like a
mystery and you wanna like when they
give you that information that's the
enjoyment factor for me they obviously
have a whack him they cool personalities
that are way better than sort of online
like NOK said but how they like it's so
over-the-top crazy that when they like
they tell you how is what I enjoy being
so good to like he's a beta tester he's
a good gamer that's his power these
people are just intelligent they're not
elaborate strategy that they explain to
you afterwards compared to oh I'm good
at video games
yeah but same thing with them their
needs they're stuck in their home no one
needs them in the real world but they're
really good at games Oh guess why you're
transported to a world where games can
make you the best person ever here you
go
save me this is a realistic show that
you never know you might fall into a
magical world the gate no one's trying
to convince you to stuff man well this
is it's a similar premise listen for two
seconds it's ordered online you have
Kido
how did he beat each flip at the end of
the first season
that's right through hacks it made no
sense he was killed he's ordered with
willpower comes back from the dead to
kill oh okay how does it beat the main
bad guy the second arc well let me
elaborate for you my friend he hacks the
game because he enters the ID of the guy
who controlled the last game which sort
of gives them you know ultra powers in
this games kill fairy king guy now quite
frankly you don't need to say I enter id
Heathcliff which was the other guy's
name
well it had no password I mean like you
could just enter ID just say anyone's
name and all of a sudden you have their
app that makes zero sense
okay so that tells me the second bad guy
are you noticing a trend here okay so I
understand
you you make a good point however I'm
not saying the sword our line is a great
anime balsa can you explain to me how in
no game no life Shira and Sora were able
to beat that virtual reality game at the
end of season 1 yeah I was amazing
you thought help you thought that was
amazing that was a complete [ __ ]
edwards was that man at least it's like
crazy over-the-top strategy that
explained to you afterwards alike it
says realistic impossible even though
it's like crazy like it majorly at least
it makes believe and also another thing
that it does if you look at a average
picture of QT though you will be you
know all of an emotional emotionless
face or like this stupid smile that
doesn't reach his eyes and whatever but
if you look at the picture of Sora he
has some crazy expression that's the
differences between the anime sort of a
line is trying to be an edgy you know
fantasy world that they survive through
hardships and whatever and quite frankly
it ain't okay no game no life on the
other hand you look at the guy he's
having a great time the point of this
anime is to have a great time it's not
an edgy you know your life is in danger
show so you're you're saying that the
aesthetic is what's puts no game no life
forward yet
aesthetic is the second important part
second most important part of any anime
right on your story it is also really
aesthetically pleasing show that's just
me though I actually the colors were
pretty stupid personally what no stop
talking about si oh please window is I
can understand like your arguments for
no game like the characters and stuff
but there are a lot of things that make
me think you know you can't really hate
on Sao and appreciate no game no life
because there was so many that's mad
Ojai that it's basically a super power
and no one can relate to it in the real
world then it's a
dude we discussed this for enough time
and it's not even an anime this year I
suggest you just forfeit and move on
no [ __ ] tonight be an intellectual to
understand that the complex knew I knew
once's that is no game no party brothers
let us let us analyze intellectually the
bathtub scenes were stopping at this
sister and Stephanie girl but anyway
Mack you were gonna say something oh it
does the UH man so since I've been away
my memories also gone oh yeah it does
the Death Note
live-action count as an anime even
though I wasn't an anime thank you it's
not really an anime but it was pretty
big steaming pile of [ __ ] sorry sorry
pardon my french lush it it was a I hope
that's the thing I had hopes for it - oh
I had I went into into it with like the
most open mind possible is like this is
e this this I expected an American
adaptation and unfortunately that's
exactly what I got but in all all the
wrong ways so funny cuz I was I was
asked like on a yo knucks like my first
yo nuts un a thing like if you could
pick one anime / there to be a live
adaptation for what would you pick and I
so Death Note that's the one thing you
like nail it normally yeah you'd think
they could have you know I'm not saying
old animate live actions are bad that's
just stupid but this is my song like a
lot of annotations are good some there
are a few like I've started watching did
you know erased has a live action I
didn't know this but Netflix and it's
pretty darn good they did the whole show
so far it's actually really solid its
American American or Japanese it's
Japanese it's Japanese I had no clue
either I was looking at like two things
to watch and I saw race I'm like oh it's
on Netflix now so I wanted to check out
the first episode because I
it was a good show I wanted to watch it
again I'm like way these are these are
real people this isn't this isn't what I
thought it was and it how long did it
take until you picked it up but they
were real people as soon as I saw the
first the first Asian and I was like oh
that's a there really that's the real
Asian not another one of them cartoon
Asians you hear real real
a man I grew up in the backwoods let me
tell you about the backwards what no
I've actually noticed there's a lot of
interesting Japanese out of patient
death no to the Japanese updations of
Death Note I really enjoy like it's not
exactly like the anime but it tries to
be faithful to the anime and it might be
a cultural thing because in Japan anime
is culturally accepted and widespread so
when they adapt they stick close to the
enemy whereas in the West they keeps
thinking oh we have to dumb it down or
you know make an American so that people
understand cuz you know people are
stupid so then let's have Misa what
what's her name what was her name
Miah Miah Miah yeah it was Misa but
let's have Mia and all this be a
cheerleader but she has the kind of
mindset that no cheerleader would ever
have because she's like the opposite of
what a cheerleader would like all this
stupid stuff and that's what I think
kills these Western adaptations it's
like they're they try to take a good
work but then completely rework it
because they're like oh stupid our
stupid fans are not gonna understand
those Japanese cultures so we gotta we
gotta make it different and then they
change what's good about it mmm I like
that Willem Dafoe isn't it that's it
yeah that's it oh I love Dan but he was
the intended not much no and you never
even really saw his face either I think
that they tried to they tried to use
that to their advantage because I know
like the original Japanese live-action
adaptations that's kind of why they sort
of blew issues cuz they spent so much of
their money making Ryuga look good that
the rest of it look like [ __ ] now this
time they're like wait okay well there
is red but that's right boy Lee did not
look good
no he was just like in the shadows the
whole time so you barely I loved right
was actually the best thing in class was
the best bother me the film whatever II
really don't know it was a pretty
graphic a single thing that I liked
about the movie the voice the voice of
rheic of clever yeah I guess that's it I
got my I got my spider-man from that
that's all that this fireman G Green
Goblin
oh yeah but that's that's not even good
they didn't have the potato chip seen as
Shiraz says or and we all want
importance of the potato chip seen here
right no yeah I know you know who knows
it Jeff no stop my video you did a video
about the potato chip scenes aw but that
was a craziest video I did it to me on
how its are like a sarcastic thing
making you know so awesome but I meant
both things i ghastly
I said to the Japanese like you know I
should actually serious one and it was
just my points just take it seriously it
was very good
yeah man yeah Knox you're good youtubers
so you know people coffee you that's
what happens original Inc says he like
ghost in the shell' live-action
adaptation I still have to see that like
I know a lot of people hated on it but I
don't want to make this you know that
call and because I really don't like
this whole Oh Scarlett Johansson played
a character that's supposed to be Asian
like okay [ __ ] off the Japanese
adaptation of Full Metal Alchemist
Brotherhood it's all Japanese people
obviously even though it's supposed to
be set in a Western nation who cares
we're not gonna argue about it like I
don't like people get butthurt for
stupid [ __ ] like that
personally I saw I saw it in on a plane
that's where I catch up on my crappy
American on a small screen I couldn't
even finish it to be honest if I like it
though no no well why do you think it
couldn't pinch it oh okay you couldn't
finish it you couldn't finish it maybe
because the plane was about to island or
did you just say look that was
not the reason I been like switch that
rewatched like Pirates of the Caribbean
or something means Andreea yeah the
first one goes I watched like the first
four or something now they're still mate
but no like usually when I want to
plaintiffs when I catch up on the Marvel
movies like Ant Man and [ __ ] like that
that's why I watched The Avengers also
and man was terrible
Ant Man was okay I thought it was funny
like again that's one of those like
nothing compares with dead people like
that [ __ ] dog Deadpool is amazing
it's like [ __ ] old school probably
the best Marvel uh one of the best
Marvel films I've watched yeah also I
like Thor I haven't seen the latest door
I have to see that one that's quite good
just because I like like Norse mythology
and stuff well I saw Wonder Woman in up
on a plane yeah I saw all this stuff on
planes terrible woman is not Marvel well
and I also don't really have a desire to
see it I don't know terrible Wonder
Woman No mad it's very bad I've been
like and you know what else the problem
is
Superman versus Batman was such a
letdown to me like that I don't really
feel a need to keep watching those
because like that movie took itself so
seriously do so much in one movie that
it just felt like completely like what
the [ __ ] is out there
but anyway should probably go back to
anime oh yeah good night's blood yes yes
terrible yeah I gotta agree with you
nuts it wasn't my type of show okay well
then I don't want to agree with you so
we'll move on eviler live that was
awesome well that was I like that that
was good oh there we go
I'm sorry but I actually did enjoy even
live even though as a Chinese anime I
still enjoyed it yeah that knew his bed
aren't all anime Chinese like know what
[ __ ] with me right now Oh anime are
chinese peopre what do you mean I like
to wash off any vintage like 20 magic
Regan nights and magic yes good like
good like I did like that I don't say I
don't like it that's bad yeah he liked
it I remember I watched like the first
three episodes and I was like this is so
stupid and pointless he was like no
everything what happened didn't need to
happen for example its economy we
frankly the main character could just be
born in that world their character died
he got reincarnated into a lolly looking
boy and yeah he's super smarty builds
robots and yeah that was the whole show
total opposite of saga of Technic people
just went total opposite direction there
yeah like I agree with you Knox there
was no need for dr. excite it should
have been just a normal fantasy anime
yeah there's been a trap either I don't
know what the factor they killed him off
the first episode like first of the
first few minutes he got hit I didn't
think that was a big deal but uh Nick
because I would love to talk about
coconut on boot which was a disaster I'm
not finished watching token ranbu
Nick in distress if he wants to see a
one-punch man alive action and I want to
see one starring mystique Rebecca I want
to see why misty
oh because he's born okay no ki cosplays
as one punch man he's great that's a
streak on he's like you know
yeah he's brilliant but know what misty
even his personality could be like he's
like a chill dude he's evil makes
YouTube videos like I feel like he would
be you know a good site though it chill
dude on YouTube but in the DNC's
bit of a sassy [ __ ] in the good way
in the good way yeah and I feel like I
feel like Misty's the type of guy who
looks like a supermarket sale and he's
like oh [ __ ] I gotta get on that you
know I loved uh niju
edge of the season was great for me well
we're not talking about good anime but
well hello why can you explain to me why
to 30 year old people
hold hands and like ejaculate everywhere
[Music]
from holding hands what are you talking
about Ned Juno Xue su-mei they didn't
need what do you mean exactly a woman
very much this is this is why I haven't
watched most of these bad because I have
let people like knocks give me like
previews and I'm like I'm never watching
this [ __ ] on the bottom my honest
descriptions those otherwise known
watching me but and I guess can I just
say [ __ ] you good caster for life he
suggested a code yes live-action
adaptation with goals end as Lelouch and
me as Suzaku
[ __ ] you you know that's that's a woman
listen up listen up I've been at the
game for a long time he's big in the in
the [ __ ] community of code because he
deserves to at least be table can at
least goes in should be Suzaku animatic
you should probably be like Jeremiah and
pedantic romantic it I would be okay
with Jeremiah I would also be okay with
Olga but I get the true I was stupid I
get to choose she gets cast as Valletta
that's all I ask
scarlet johansson wants to know if she
can do you accept
no not Scarlett Johansson I'm sorry okay
I'm sorry I know I said you know we
gotta get that I supposed to be from
Brazil so we got to get a nice I will be
well don't worry I got that who is Nina
what was her personality like I didn't
know this girl
you see what a woman loves the table
very much Rika
yes Yun watch moles shed that like
normal people watch so we can't talk
with you it's like what is me none like
what is she like that related to me
blade like this is like SWAT cog a
admitting one of the previous streams
that he didn't watch full Malcolm his
Brotherhood except with recon it's like
every other rank a fate we learned that
he didn't watch something that everyone
should have watched so it's like it's
like swag cocky but to the hundreds who
the [ __ ] is Miyazaki by the way everyone
so put down looking me but cat that was
the funniest thing I've ever seen by the
way a cat a few people mentioned neo
yoki look in the chat neo ki o was not
bad and yo-yo Kyo should not be
discussed in the worst anime and Yuri
okiya was to quote one excellent anime
youtuber brilliant that you yes right
now how do you guys feel about koi - oh
so or whatever I don't know how it's
pronounced yeah yes that's right I liked
it it was pretty bad it started off good
I liked at the beginning and then I gave
up on it of course you like to listen ya
know the ending though he couldn't
choose between them that was kind of
disappointing I'll finally pitch well
premise for the entire anime makes zero
sense okay you have people what's once
it turned sixteen because I mean the
whole premise was it was bad it was it
was quite obvious like I was middle of
explaining what I was saying and then
you interrupted me to say what are you
talking about how stupid Stan thank you
thank you man that mustache wiggle
anyway yeah the whole premise is
basically once they turn 16 they get a
text you are to marry this bimbo okay
which is a wonderful thing now if
everyone 16 when they get this text why
do two people get it at the same time
him and this person he's supposed to
marry because everyone turning 16 at the
same time
okay well that
just nitpicking massive plot holes but
just nitpicking aside from that I mean I
don't want to say like poor gay guys
right they master the game counter so
maybe a fast name maybe they take that
into consideration
I would assume list when you're like
human race gay guys ain't populating
human race you know can we not get into
this the point is Castlevania was
garbage and I've said that many times
[ __ ] you Castlevania was so entertaining
for me Jose you made a video saying and
then you regretted it later after I
broke it down for you why Castlevania
was crap so don't worry don't worry all
day and a man we know it's good and
that's all that matters
see Mac knows no you can't I got you
good it's like man you have to play the
game and the other game in the third
game and then you'll understand it's
like no adaptations stand for themselves
I didn't play the game adaptation was
bad I agree that they should stand as
like standalone I did put the games so
maybe I'm biased but I wanted like what
are your points as to why I know I
watched your video I just can't remember
what are your points as to why it's bad
no I didn't even make a video on it but
I just mentioned like I ran cafe
I swear or maybe you ranted last frat
cafe up to me about it yeah I was right
and you Briggs you're always like you
don't even know what's going on so
you're like is this a video is this a
ramp café's is happening right now
or am i in the chat but no it was just
the plot takes way too long to actually
get started it's only at the end of the
season which is like four up says
whatever then we meet the Sun guy and
then it gets like all [ __ ] now things
are actually happening then also we have
the historical inaccuracies they've just
pissed me off in terms of like what just
Castlevania for historical accuracy
because it's talking about this is the
1400s in Romania what do you
completely inaccurate how you ask me how
it's inaccurate no sorry it's based a
lot dracula who is a real historical
person however there are no turks
in romania at this time the whole point
was the turks invading the balkans at
this time there's also demons raining
from the sky in this attack romania
didn't happen Romania is Orthodox
Christian meanwhile the Catholic Church
for some reason controls the world of
Castlevania the creators of this gamers
troll did no research whatsoever
and finally the animation is terrible
like I said look at the faces of these
people and you will see their faces
don't change if they're my angry if
they're laughing they're fake the facial
animation is some of the worst I've ever
seen
so yeah it's just it was a bad for my
rebuttal the historical inaccuracies
thing is kind of stupid as an anime but
like other than that it's not ok thunder
anime Kanna me cuz from the UK I'm sure
I'll say how crazy good English Ikki was
this season I have a lot senior cheeky
dude do we lose you
anime ik there's a long oh that's great
well I completely agree with you with
Castlevania on every single one of your
points can I continue ok very much
paddle I don't really con started
talking with some be dragged oh yeah
because you guys are talking about anime
and even watch oh yeah entire stream
also it's this is very much a Caprice
eagle in the fans like the the first
episode was a very a little bit slow
I liked the introduction of like Dracula
and
then it flops over like to the main
story it's just like you know how you
describe Dragon Ball super this being an
enjoyable watch
that's my same thought process here
watching these guys kill monsters and
demons and vampires is just entertaining
the matter Emily that's the problem it
doesn't really get going things with
Dracula Sun and [ __ ] now it's gonna get
interesting
what it didn't get interesting form at
the end of the first season just like at
the end of the first season it's like
okay now we have the main cast these
guys are kind of rivals like the the
main dude whatever his name is Josh or I
forget and Dracula's son little Dracula
attractive tough attractive Josh dragon
Josh dragon jock and Josh green animate
can't wait for season 2
Locke I would say don't judge it until
you watch like the next season I'm sure
there will I know you don't you know you
know that's the one piece thing it's
like yo judge until your types of 578
bro it was like an introduction to the
series only four episodes it wasn't a
standalone thing it might happen when a
three Episode per in intro prologue know
whatever the word log yeah that thing so
whatever episodes was like an
introduction to the world which I
thought they did really roll after why
Dracula did what he did and how the
world turned out the way it was like I
thought it was really well done yeah oh
my god thank you for bringing that up
his wife wants him to be a normal person
and to help people and instead of hurt
them that's whole whole her whole
mission in life is to help people
what does he do when she's killed so now
I'm gonna slaughter all these innocent
people in how they're not everyone's a
good person honey he loved that
individual and now he wants revenge on
the world he was originally like a what
you want a nice girl he's dishonouring
her memory beyond people you love you
lose sense of rationality not a lot to
do but he's not being logical because he
like someone his love died broke he's
like I will give you a year for me to
think about this and then I'll still do
it and it will still be stupid it's not
like he did it the spur of the moment
hello this is the issue I had with the
Sasuke and Itachi Sasuke is angry at
Itachi because he killed whatever
spoiler stuff and he basically after all
this he realizes that he taught you did
everything he did for the good of the
village whatever everyone watched Naruto
or should have at this point so um so
thank you
basically he then learns this whole plan
that everything he thought she did was
for the good of the village and how he
taught she had like this tough life
basically doing all this for the village
and he died she dies and he's like I am
gonna destroy the head village how dare
they make me God she said that's not
what he taught you would walk here but
yeah that's an issue I had with Sasuke
also I didn't like Castlevania I just I
thought it was very men very men yes I
know what black people it is far
superior to Castlevania adamak will like
things like Dragon Ball super and will
like things like black clover and then
put down Castlevania and no game no life
so whatever that seems personal
great you didn't even though he's got
it's not a - I don't now I don't even
have a little sister so I'm not even
sensitive to the issue but when it's
just pandering for the sake of pandering
there's no creativity it's like oh he's
attracted to his little sister it's like
first of all why second of
so many times that's not what happened
in no gaming life but if it's not the
point I'm just saying I also hated
Castlevania and I also preferred black
over to Castlevania okay thank you thank
you Knox when you look I'm still on firm
ground
I'm still on firm find one little thing
about a show like historical I gave you
four things forecast what Bill gave no
life the characters are amazing like you
just wait is Steph a good character in
any way no but her point is that get
ripped on because you're the boss
character the butt of all the jokes and
therefore the platoons
yes she's a good character but even
because she's a bad character come over
man like what's the darkness guy he's
pretty cool and Japanese actually okay
yeah what are you asking
one good character in black lower hasta
okay whatever next up you know yeah yeah
their clothes are new arrivals but they
actually like each other they're friends
to like I thought it was a it's quite a
I like the girl Noel Paulson terrible
Noel is good anchor hold on hold on I
think that in terms of again no gain the
life I did finish that enema I didn't
drop it I didn't hate it it's just not
as good as I would have liked it to be a
rising star and the Chad he says green
lagoon is his favorite anime little
known crossover between Gurren Lagann
and black lagoon
it was quite epic it was quite appetizer
I love blocks the goon man I wish I
still need to watch it
oh really should you want to much into
it
where they fight Nazis in Thailand there
you go I'm in sold would you say have
you guys seen nanatsu no taizai
haven't yeah
little-known fact Briggs makes videos
about some of these sins
you just peels enough the seven deadly
sends the other one oh my god oh the
seven mortal sins okay tell me all the
seven deadly sins
seven deadly sins and it was this edgy
garbage yeah I watched the first episode
of them yeah it's a very bad I've seen I
commented it on one of my videos to
watch it so I did yes I wanna watch it
because sometimes I see these ridiculous
entry shows and I actually enjoy them
where people he mostly bright this is
crap and I'm like you're just a prude
you're just afraid of breasts but no I
haven't actually seen it so I have to
now what's happening
speaking of itchy have you met a no gal
no was the fat guy it was hairy on top
it was the first three episodes and yeah
for me like I might have continued if it
wasn't for the fat guy and the [ __ ]
lolly [ __ ]
but that was me is like man I don't want
any part that's what turned everyone off
is this the show from the dude who made
sorter problem no all right okay
so what I was gonna say is I think
that's what turned I've run off it
turned me off as while I dropped it like
the for two episodes and then afterwards
I picked it back up and last five to six
episodes were surprisingly like good
haha see that knocks see that my boy
some cute relationship development and
like it went away from like lolly
whatever the [ __ ] that beginning was
yeah stupid thing and this is the sting
with no game no life that I'm talking
about these people that make these enemy
they latch onto these stupid tropes they
think it's they're having a blast like
oh yeah lollies is a thing let's make it
thinking this anime because it's a trope
and then they ruin it for so many people
and they don't even end up watching it
because it's so stupid and in your face
it's like stop with the tropes man be a
little bit more original well you don't
have to have a little sister character I
was just in almost every [ __ ] episode
of Hodgson mention about it really
pissed me off
listen anime your can you tell me right
now your whole problem with no game no
life was the lolly garbage that was
happening no it's not just that so it
wait your points cuz I agree with you
now as an issue but don't know I know
that was part of it like but just in
general pandering so even if there was
no sister the blatant fanservice with
Steph that didn't make any sense and
like was just like in your face you
could tell there was fan pandering the
stuff that where these guys are was
hilarious in no game no life although
the factors did not matter here with the
plot the fact that these guys are otaku
so their uses in the real world but bono
now they're brilliant geniuses in the
game world that also I thought was just
fan pandering and again like I said
their intelligence is so old P it's not
like you can't follow it it's not like
light versus L right it's not oh it's
there oh [ __ ] that's brilliant because I
know how how he thought of that it's
like how are these people thinking that
moves ahead it's not possible so that's
what frustrated me also I want what the
anime I want to see is caster for life
suggested it called gore and death
Alchemist I think that might be the best
animal all time I saw last year you my
man if you ever wanna watch it's
Dragonball bleach peace dip it in right
now
I I am actually watching it so there you
go so there you go I don't even have to
watch context answer because I'm
watching black clover am i right anyway
no revenge to walk oh yeah scums scrum
and resumption comes wish comes with the
different one I'm talking about America
no revenge okay what are basically this
is no I like a I like money collusion
and school is a big girl
what again it wasn't amazing describe it
but then he was just gonna gave up like
[ __ ] it you know what I mean basically
anything that I like not just just can't
he can't be bothered to explain I would
have loved to explain it briefly but
like I don't want to have to talk over
recon say yes you say about it I just
like it I feel like since I've lost the
ability but I like the whole plot about
ok ok Rica hold on now you wanted
revenge about Ivan the girl that bullied
him when he was bad you know she it was
it was quite committed cuz funny ok
recon thought it was funny he thought it
was good funny Briggs you were gonna say
something oh I'll just saying that like
I feel like we do not have this problem
as bad before like we can't even speak
in this chat maybe just the combination
of people they we see my talking over
each other
their names are recon and Knox when you
have recon and knocks they go out at to
the point where I can't do anything like
I just I just like make fake accounts
and talk [ __ ] on their YouTube channels
for revenge that's that's all I can do
that's all I can do
but yeah we do have to try to talk one
person at a time and we're just about
that is never gonna happen at a Mac and
you know it
IV cuts all it off at the basil II don't
blame me for this garbage alright week
on I'll keep that in mind next time I'm
deciding who's gonna be a Red Cafe
anyway oh you know I'm her I'm part of
the original crew you can't take me out
of the zone it's actively not part of
the original crew the original crew was
Mac and Rose and Brin brakes and Briggs
and Briggs and Brad Briggs
yes Briggs gate before black credit
guide then black credit guy then I
believe then it was cyanide blizzard and
then you so yeah you're not that mylar
like you're like Jen for your I better
be considered dead one yeah Knox you're
one of the new ones but like you show me
out on your channel so I love you
you get autumn air Egypt - because of
that rant cafes on my channel I think
that's a higher level fine you can have
honorary gen1 this week moderator
himself he's brought like screaming into
them just read screaming into his body
pillow anyway I love you all
that's my line I love you all
platonically anyway but it's time to
wrap it up guys
so I will leave it to you will do go one
by one again and just kind of you can
say who you are what you do and if you
want to accentuate again what your worst
anime of this year was you can dimension
also guys in the chart thank you for
joining us leave a like if you enjoy
rank a fan you can join us every week at
5 p.m. Eastern Standard Time some times
on my channel maybe other times on noxes
when I'm out of town or something I
think it's a good option to be able to
switch it up but okay - you knocks hello
tis me
NOx Taku believe it or not I have a
channel here on YouTube and I do anime
stuff so at this point it's pretty much
three categories there's analysis
there's parody and there's Naruto which
is slowly taking over with as scary as
that sounds I'm working on lots of
things whenever let's not self promote
too much just go subscribe and whatever
and Naruto is bortles dead right for
those of you who do not know Naruto's
actually boards is that okay guy how to
show um makkal not oh right that was
your fault makkal no that's me hey hi
that's that's my name
well I make contents on the youtubes a
lot of it's just kind of like half a
surgery I recently uploaded my first
first cosplay video it's pretty
fantastic it's on my channel right now
especially if you like Razer oh I said
or even you did I suggest you go check
that out other than that I'm mostly just
on Twitch which is twitch.tv slash
Makela but we're gonna try and put out
more stuff in the future I have a few
collaboration projects in the
in the works and some other nifty stuff
that should be coming out it sounds so
fancy not it's really would be to follow
us all on Twitter quite everyone on
Twitter and also everyone's channel
links are in the description just to
remind you recon to you yeah what's up
my boys it's your boy recon and I do
them anime top tens so yeah check out my
channel if you're interested in that
type of [ __ ] if you want more anime
recommendations because everyone knows
that I have the shittiest taste of anime
of all time say whether you're proud of
it as [ __ ] for some reason yes I'm proud
of it I'm known as the harem king yeah
he is known as the harem King to himself
to say apparently some others you all
know on the harem King you know you're
good parent king in your heart okay
let's just leave it at that
thank you who is hard at work you could
say during this dream ready for this
ready for this oh hi hello welcome back
I'm video worker I typed it in the chat
guys get real yeah I have the channel
all the anime I will supply you with all
the facts you ever need I will explain
concepts analysis I don't know some cool
stuff contract me out thank you yeah you
see guys when you have to make a choice
between work and anime there is no
choice at all is there Thank You Briggs
for joining us yeah disappointed that's
so actually couldn't join us today yeah
I don't haven't heard from him today so
I asked them on discord what's going on
he hasn't replied maybe he's busy maybe
he's working I don't know but we'll see
about next week hopefully he'll get back
to me anyway guys thank you for joining
me everyone in the chat thank you for
chatting and everyone who was
out about Suzaku caster for life I will
never forgive you
oh yeah uh see you guys next time and
until next time see us bass go
[Music]